une page se tourne à cayenne en guyane
avec la disparition du marché à la
crique à un marché de poissons en plein
air qui à partir d'aujourd'hui sera
concentrée dans une halle couverte
une révolution pour les guyanais qui
n'étaient pas tous d'accord d'ici
quelques jours tentera fini de
l'ambiance de la crique le sait sont de
ses couleurs et surtout de ses odeurs
les vendeurs de la crise ne vont
transférer leurs activités au vieux-port
au marché d'intérêt régional moyennant
un loyer mensuel de 3 35 euros
ils bénéficieront limoges toutes
équipées possédant chambre froide
atelier de découpe balance électronique
ou encore et caillau pneumatiques
cette vendeur à l'instar de david
etienne pour déjà franchi le pas c'est
pour nous une certaine forme de remise
aux normes des choses parce que en fait
dans la conduite dans les conditions
dans lesquelles nous livrons au marché
aux poissons actuelle bon cela n'est
plus possible
donc c'est une
garantie de l'hygiène au niveau
sanitaire qu'est ce qui s'en suit est
pour moi aussi ce sera un grand bien le
marché d'intérêt régional lemire comme
on l'appelle est aujourd'hui
techniquement après il a reçu ses
premiers poissons aujourd'hui les
premiers qui sont attendus peu le
vendredi 2 avril prochain sur le coup